[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines et aujourd'hui
nous allons traiter d'un sujet
d'actualité la pénurie de composants
électroniques et pour en parler nous
sommes à voisins le bretonneux sur le
site de l'entreprise euros composant une
entreprise créée en 1989 et qui est
spécialisé dans la distribution de
composants électroniques elle fait face
aujourd'hui à cette pénurie mondiale de
composants électroniques c'est au
programme de ce 27e numéro du sky échos
l'école de 1600 et l'entreprise sylla se
sont associées pour former des jeunes à
la cybersécurité un partenariat pour
enrichir la formation dans ce domaine à
montigny le bretonneux
depuis plusieurs mois le monde connaît
une pénurie de composants électroniques
si tu as voisins le bretonneux le
distributeur aux composants est impacté
par ce phénomène et si vous voulez
augmenter la croissance des entreprises
ils vont simplement augmenter leurs
échanges donc dé multiplier les échanges
donc c'est le but de cette journée
aujourd'hui c'était en 2016 la première
édition du sky business dès la
convention d'affaires organisés au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines et la sixième édition aura lieu
le jeudi 25 novembre en ligne déjà à 400
entreprises ont prévu d'y participer
pour 1200 en rendez vous d'affaires déjà
à calais et si vous souhaitez vous
inscrire pour y participer vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et parmi les
participants au sky business de
l'entreprise euros composants dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
avec son directeur général nous allons
parler de son activité et des
problématiques liées à la pénurie de
composants électroniques et son
directeur général c'est julien berger
bonjour bonjour enchanté
alors heureux composants qu'est ce que
c'est
recomposant c'est une société qui fait
de la distribution de composants
électroniques on a différents types de
composants on a des semi conducteurs
nous avons également des modules à
partir de ces semi conducteurs qui
peuvent être des modules d'affichage des
modules de communication sans fil des
calculateurs
des alimentations et nous signons des
accords de partenariat avec des sociétés
étrangères
les fabricants sont essentiellement
localisés en asie ça va être le japon
taïwan la chine et la corée et notre
mission c'est de les commercialiser sur
le territoire français mais également
dans les produits dans les pays
manufacturier de nos clients français
qui sont l'europe de l'est le
maghreb et l'asie du sud-est ont donc on
ça représente à peu près 35 % de notre
activité vous êtes situé à voisins le
bretonneux ça fait 30 ans que vous êtes
situés ici où vous étiez avant ailleurs
alors l'entreprise a commencé il ya 30
ans à saint cloud mais au bout de deux
ans elle a migré sur saint-quentin pas
dans ses locaux là parce que la société
était un peu plus petit il y avait cinq
personnes c'était à 500 m d'ici et donc
dans ses locaux ça fait maintenant une
dizaine d'années
qu'on y est installée on accueille à peu
près 50 personnes pour un chiffre
d'affaires d'un peu plus de 60 millions
d'euros est derrière vous vous avez des
exemples de ce que vous pouvez proposer
notamment à vos clients alors c'est un
un panel extrêmement réduit
donc il ya des cartes électroniques de
ce type et
il y en a des plus gros salaires il
s'agit d'un contrôleur de dalles
tactiles donc c'est des choses qui
peuvent être implémentées dans un autre
bouc
notamment mais pour des applications
plus industrielles ici on a des semi
conducteurs donc le composant encapsulés
dans des boîtiers donc on va avoir des
boîtiers en montage de surfaces ou des
boîtiers en picot et est ici vous avez
donc des puces électroniques qui sont
déjà des coupes et donc ce qu'ils sont
des bouts de wever qui sont découpées
suivant la taille du composant et qui
vont dans ces boîtiers l'un est alors la
pénurie on voit un phénomène mondial
aujourd'hui à une pénurie sur les
composants électroniques et notamment
les semi conducteurs ces semi
conducteurs là qui sont concernés par
par la pénurie
exactement donc là le premier la
première pénurie elle elle affecte les
les wafers dans lequel on va fabriquer
ces puces et la concrètement l'impact
sur votre société c'est quoi par rapport
à cette pénurie alors c'est de gérer des
crises puisque donc on a pas mal de
clients qui sont en chômage technique
en arrêt de production
c'est des composants qui coûte plus cher
pour pouvoir
accéder à ces composants dans des délais
qui sont raisonnables
quand on dit raisonnable c'est 30 40
semaines alors qu'il ya deux ans on
était plutôt dans les huit à douze
semaines mais 30 à 40 semaines c'est
mieux que pas de composants du tout et
sur certains composants on est au delà
de 52 semaines voire 100 semaines de
délais de livraison et justement on va
te descendre au niveau logistique oui
parce que vous avez du stock finalement
malgré cette pénurie on y va tout de
suite
et nous avons rejoint alain refus veille
bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le manager logistique chez
euro composants alors ici on est dans un
atelier qu'est ce qui s'y passe
concrètement ici alors ici c'est
l'atelier d'intégration en fait un des
métiers de recomposant c'est de proposer
à des clients les solutions custom qui
permettent justement de venir mettre à
jour différents procès sur des produits
qui sont vendus donc des écrans des
cartes etc c'est le cas par exemple ici
en face à exactement donc on vient
rajouter un moment donné des cartes
mémoire pour pouvoir répondre à un
cahier des charges client c'est ce qui
fait que le produit les véritablement
dédié
et ensuite on a toute une phase de
contrôle qui est fait c'est à dire que
l'on réalise des petites et moyennes
séries et on vient ensuite très emballé
le produit faire une fiche de contrôle
la certifier et ensuite ça repart en
logistique pour pouvoir est expédiée eh
bien on va aller dans le magasin manar
près mais c'est parti
[Musique]
donc ici c'est un magasin qui fait à peu
près 500 m² il ya 3000 références
environ qui sont stockés des références
des toutes petites pièces que vous
pouvez voir ici
qui sont à chaque fois étiquetés avec
codes-barres et toutes les informations
nécessaires et ensuite c'est sont ces
mêmes pièces d'ailleurs une petite
parenthèse qu'on va retrouver à
l'atelier d'intégration que nous avons
vu précédemment et qui vont nous
permettre d'alimenter tous ces
différents chantiers donc ici les flux
qui sont traités c'est environ une
cinquantaine de commandes par jour ça
représente 60 colis en termes d'activité
c'est principalement des clients qui
sont en france y aussi des clients à
l'export et donc nous avons tout le
matériel qu'il faut pour pouvoir traiter
les expéditions les factures les
certificats de conformité et autres
documents nécessaires concrètement sur
la partie logistique comment vous est
impacté par la pénurie d'offre de semis
composants et enfin de semi conducteurs
et de composants électroniques alors
l'impact il est réel parce que m'en ont
donné on a des commandes clients qui
sont en attente ce qui est sûr c'est que
derrière les coudes approches ont
énormément augmenté
ça veut dire que pour pouvoir traiter
des imports régulièrement avec
l'inflation qu'il ya eu sur toute la
partie du transport on est tenu
néanmoins de faire venir ces pièces et
on a des coûts d'acquisition qui sont
extrêmement importants et impact est
donc en termes de quantité de pièces on
en a moins il ya sont aussi plus cher à
faire venir d'une difficulté de
traitement logistique dans la suite des
opérations et finalement vous maintenez
quand même une activité parce que il ya
une grosse demande face à cela oui oui
tout à fait au maintien d'activités
parce que recomposant a du stock celle
aussi la force du distributeur c'est de
pouvoir répondre à ces exigences clients
donc bien évidemment mais aussi un
ralentissement de l'activité il ya
néanmoins du stock qui nous permet de
tenir et de traiter les commandes comme
il se doit mais ce n'est pas toujours
facile on a des délais qui sont passés
de 50 à 60 70 semaines sur certains
produits donc oui c'est compliqué merci
à la réveille
manager logistique chéreau composants et
le sky échos se poursuit ici même à
voisins le bretonneux depuis le mois de
septembre 2021 l'école 2006 en forme 60
jeunes âgés de 16 à 30 ans aux métiers
de la cybersécurité situe à montigny le
bretonneux c'est une formation en
alternance qui dure trois ans et c'est
dans ce cadre là qu'elle collabore avec
l'entreprise silicone mais si la situer
à guyancourt un partenariat expliqué
dans ce business
[Musique]
ou
qu'arthur bataille j'ai 32 ans et je
suis dirigeant de silicone et de sylla
si la société de supers entraînements et
partenaires de l'école de 2600
oui
silas est une solution de cyber
entraînement qui permet de former des
ingénieurs des administrateurs systèmes
réseau des développeurs aux enjeux de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information axel
dreyfus 30 depuis 20 ans je suis le co
fondateur de l'école de 1600 une école
spécialisée en cybersécurité en
alternance
[Musique]
nous avons un tiers de la formation qui
est dispensée à partir de cours
magistraux et de peer-to-peer learning à
travers de promotion de 60 élèves et le
reste du temps les étudiants sont en
alternance dans les entreprises pour se
spécialiser dans les métiers de signal
c'est déjà un partenariat d'intérêt
c'est une vision commune de ce que doit
être la formation dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité nous avons des échanges à
travers sylla et silicone sur
l'écosystème et sur le besoin des
entreprises
c'est également aussi une belle
opportunité pour nous d'avoir des
alternants puisqu'on à la fois des
alternances la société silicon mais sur
la société si là pour créer des contenus
et des attaques
sur notre petite formation des échanges
réguliers par rapport au corpus de cours
par rapport aussi la plus pédagogique
on a effectivement un échange
excessivement riche pour correspondre
aux besoins des entreprises c'est
également aussi un lieu pour la
formation le russe killing notamment des
demandeurs d'emploi et donc de pouvoir
les amener vers les métiers de la
cybersécurité ce qui a aussi un fort
intérêt pour le compte de silicone
bénéficient des cris rauques arthur et
ses équipes aujourd'hui sur
l'élaboration du syllabus évident on
remonte auprès d'arthur aussi tout et
perception qu'on peut avoir un regard de
signaux faibles par rapport aux besoins
du marché
c'était une mutualisation de moyens et
en termes dhafra évidemment on a aussi
des échanges croisés aujourd'hui sur les
formations et personnes qui sont formés
aujourd'hui par part s'il est comme ici
là sur leurs cyber aujourd'hui sont
souvent kurtag deux élèves ça nous
permet de cohabiter avec ces jeunes qui
sont les futurs la cybersécurité de
demain ne les avoir à la fois pour nous
en tant que alternant mais également en
tant que futur potentiel d'utilisateurs
et peut-être même employés des deux
solutions que son sitcom et scylla
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission que vous pouvez
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
ou sur l'application mobile à bientôt
sur tv 70
[Musique]